[Music]
magical fairy tales have always taken
place in gorgeous and fantastic places
Disney films have made us dream of
finding our true love and being whisked
away to a magical land but would you
believe us if we told you some of these
magical places are actually real if
you're new to our channel don't forget
to subscribe and give our video a big
thumbs up get ready because today we
journey into 10 Disney movie locations
that exist in real life
Aladdin the Taj Mahal in the 1992 film
Aladdin we were able to follow
Aladdin's adventures through the city of
Agrabah the charming riff raff Aladdin
roamed the streets in search of his next
meal and he encountered the beautiful
princess in disguise jasmine in the
slums of the city Aladdin was able to
show Jasmine the amazing view from his
home the Sultan's palace of Agrabah came
to view in all its grandeur II the
palace itself was inspired by the Taj
Mahal in India the city of Agrabah in
Aladdin is also a nod to the city of
Agra where the Taj Mahal is located and
you see them side-by-side
it's easy to see how similar they are
could you believe that this gorgeous
palace is actually a mausoleum the Taj
Mahal was commissioned in 1632 by
Emperor Shah Jahan and took 20 years to
build he wanted his wife our shoe man
banu begum better known as Mumtaz Mahal
to be buried there after she died during
childbirth the beautiful structure is
built of white marble and sometimes
seems to change color depending on
sunlight or moonlight the structure is
inlaid with semi-precious stones like
Jade amethyst and turquoise Sleeping
Beauty nice shrine Stein Castle when we
think of princess castles we usually
think of the iconic castle in Disney's
Sleeping Beauty this gorgeous castle is
so iconic that it has even been featured
in Disney's first theme park in
California Disneyland
Sleeping Beauty Castle is a popular
photo-op spot for all park goers if
you've ever dreamed of living in this
castle we have good news
Sleeping Beauty's castle was inspired by
the neuschwanstein castle in germany
it's easy to see why walt shows this
castle as an inspiration
it looks just like a fairytale castle
already the castle was commissioned by
King Ludwig is the second in 1869 Ludwik
was known for being eccentric and
innovative he came up with many projects
but this was the most notable he wanted
a castle built on a steep rock high
above village what makes this castle
different from any of those in its time
was its bright colors the rooms in the
castle also displayed King Ludwig's
over-the-top and eccentric personality
with its fairytale location in the
Bavarian Alps in Germany it's easy to
understand why Walt Disney fell in love
with this in the first place the Little
Mermaid chateau de chillon if you've
ever wanted to be part of Ariel's world
and live in Prince Eric's castle we've
got a surprise for you how many of us
wanted to rock Ariel's pink dress
get your Dingle hoppers and gadgets
ready because we are taking you to
Prince Eric's castle yes this beautiful
castle is very much real and yes you can
visit Prince Eric's castle is based on
the chateau de chillon on the west end
of Lake Geneva in Switzerland the first
written account of this castle
dates back to the Year 1150 it was
originally used as a fort to control the
path between the lake and the mountains
it was later taken over in 1536 by the
Bernese it was used as a fortress
Arsenal in prison for 260 years the
castle then became a national property
of the canton of Vaud in 1803 the
British poet Lord Byron visited the
castle in 1816 it was inspired by the
story of one of its inmates Byron wrote
the poem The Prisoner of Chillon which
helped make the castle famous with a
view of Lake Geneva in the Alps it's no
wonder why this was the basis for Eric's
Castle frozen Hotel des glass when
disney's frozen was released in 2013 we
all saying let it go at the top of our
lungs right we can all agree that Queen
Elsa's ballad was catchy but it was her
ice dress and ice palace that took our
breath away although we aren't sure how
to explain Elsa's ice dress and cake we
know that the ice palace is a work of
art would you like to live in else's
palace well you definitely can because
the real-life inspiration for the castle
is in the Hotel des Glass in Canada the
hotel first opened in 2001 and was
founded by G drew on but what happens
when the ice melts the hotel is only
open during the winter season and the
design varies every year the hotel
boasts 44 rooms and suites along with
ice furniture sculptures chapel bar and
a Grand Hall local artists are hired to
carve designs and sculptures the hotel
even created a frozen suite inspired by
the film that was inspired by Anna and
Elsa's bedrooms back in 2014
this gorgeous Ice Hotel is almost enough
to make us surrender the Sun because the
cold never bothered us anyway The
Hunchback of Notre Dame Notre Dame
Cathedral one of the most beautifully
animated films features a beautiful
cathedral and the bellringer Quasimodo
Disney's The Hunchback of Notre DOM is
based on Victor Hugo's novel of the same
name if the name sounds a bit familiar
is because he also wrote lay miserab
which also was turned into a musical and
a film The Hunchback of Notre Dom story
takes place in Paris France mostly
around the actual Cathedral okay so we
know that this one is pretty obvious as
the location is included in the title
but we love this film because of how
true it stays to the location the
notre-dame Cathedral was home to the
deformed hero with the biggest heart and
spirit Quasimodo we can see a lot of the
Cathedral in the animated version it is
impressive how much it looks like the
real deal
from the stained-glass windows gargoyles
and the towers the animated version is
almost indistinguishable from the real
Cathedral the filmmakers studied the
inside of the Cathedral and worked on
replicating it as best they could
unfortunately the real one does not
include talking gargoyles
or does it Emperor's New Groove Machu
Picchu Emperor Kuzco had his laughing
with his sassy personality in the 2000
film The Emperor's New Groove the
selfishness of Emperor Kuzco included
ignoring the poor and planning to build
a summer vacation home at the top of a
hill the hill however was occupied by
pocha and his growing family Cusco of
course had no regard for the family
until he was turned into a llama by the
eve
I'll use mine who wanted to rule the
Empire couscous journey is a llama not
only humbled him and bonded him to a
family it also allowed us to see his
surroundings the beautiful jungles and
mountains were inspired by the real-life
ruins of Machu Picchu in Cusco Peru yes
Emperor Kuzco was named after the city
Cusco Clara ha Machu Picchu is located
in the Peruvian Andes
its walls Terrace stairways and ramps
blend into the natural mountain setting
it is believed that Machu Picchu was
built at the height of the Inca Empire
during the 15th and 16th centuries it's
been said that the city served as an
estate for Inca emperors while others
believe it could have been an area for
testing crops and even a trade hub
either way we are glad Cusco decided not
to build a summer house here brave Ellen
Donnan castle the feisty and fiercely
independent merida charm does in the
movie braid her adventurous spirit and
skills with the bow and arrow made us
all want to move to Scotland and learn
archery of course Merida's home was
dunbroch castle which was inspired by
not one but two castles in Scotland the
first is the island donan castle which
is now one of the most visited and
important attractions in the scottish
highlands
the castles first structure was built on
the island of Donen in the 13th century
as a defense against Vikings the castle
has changed in sizes throughout the
centuries and was abandoned for 200
years lieutenant-colonel John McCrae
Gilstrap bought the island in 1911 and
spent 20 years rebuilding Elendil in the
castle we see today is the same
structure that was finished in 1932 the
second castle is done at our castle it's
it's spread across the top of a flat top
island surrounded by the North Sea the
natural pathways were destroyed to
prevent attacks but instead a new path
was cut into the cliffs we can totally
see why these two castles were used for
dunbroch the view around them is
absolutely mad
chuckle tangled mont saint-michel
disney's 2010 movie Tangled was a
magical and hairy adventure Rapunzel's
story began much the same as the
original fairy tale but was a twist this
Rapunzel was much sassier and had a pet
and bestfriend chameleon named Pascal
she was locked away in a beautiful tower
until a runaway thief Flynn Rider came
into the picture she was then able to
find out who she really was a princess
her world was set in the kingdom of
Corona which is a gorgeous island
surrounded by water Corona was inspired
by Mont saint-michel in Normandy France
the island was invaded by some of the
highest tides in Europe which means that
it was sometimes cut off from the
mainland as waters rise the first
structure on this island happened during
the 8th century whose structures served
as a monastery and was named after the
Archangel Michael the structure
temporary was turned into a prison but
closed in 1836 it was later declared
that Mont saint-michel is a historic
monument the bait was also protected as
it has been added to a list of world
heritage sites this island was
definitely worth a visit don't you think
just don't get stranded with rising
tides cars shamrock Texas Lightning
McQueen sped on two screens and the hit
movie cars although we usually think of
princesses and extravagant castles cars
provided a breath of fresh air
aside from featuring non-human
characters cars also featured very
realistic-looking locations in cars
except for the eyeballs in the talkie of
course lightning story began on the race
track as a celebrity but when he entered
the town of Radiator Springs on route 66
it started looking even more real and
for a good reason one of the shops in
the film was a real-life location
Ramon's house of body art in the film
was based on the you droppin in shamrock
Texas in 1930 highway 83 and the famous
route 66 were completed up through
shamrock Texas you drop in was built
around it in 1936 much like many shops
the building was built by JN Tyndall and
RC Lewis and costs twenty-three thousand
dollars the design represented the
popular art deco style of the 20s and
30s the building closed down when roots
t6 was decommissioned but was renovated
in 2003 thanks to a 1.7 million dollar
grant now it is a museum visitor center
and even a Tesla electric car charging
station we about lightning is a big fan
of the upgrades Beauty and the Beast
chateau de chambord love is a tale as
old as time wouldn't you say
Belen beasts love story is that of a
fantastic fairy tale the 1991 film was
full of magic including talking objects
dancing a prince and you guessed it a
castle such a beautiful castle had to
take inspiration from somewhere equally
fantastic right well the real-life
inspiration for beasts a que Prince
Adams castle was the chateau de chambord
the shampo is located in the Loire
Valley surrounded by woods
sounds a bit familiar the counts of blue
ah had originally created a palace as a
place to be used for hunting in 1518
Francis the first demolished it and
built a massive mansion the Shambaugh
has four hundred rooms 80 staircases 365
fireplaces and is full of gorgeous high
ceilings the interior is the epitome of
royal and we can definitely see where a
disney got their inspiration from the
ornate walls paintings and tapestries
scream regal now if being in here does
it make you feel like a princess we
don't know what will the live-action
film takes this inspiration further as
it all looks even more real we hope this
comes with a massive library which of
these real-life locations was your
favorite let us know in the comments
section below if you'd like to see more
videos like this don't forget to
subscribe thanks for watching
[Music]